biden's false prophets that's the focus
of tonight's angle
in the new testament book of matthew
christ
warns that we should beware of false
prophets who
come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly
are ravenous wolves well in politics and
in the media there are plenty of false
prophets who try to sell you on policies
that just end up delivering ruin instead
of results
enter the new york times over the
weekend
it published an editorial called let's
talk about higher wages
well here's their theme the nation in
the democratic party
desperately needs a replacement for the
tired story that tax cuts drive
economic growth but when you read on in
the editorial
you see that the geniuses at the times
have no clue
about what should happen next here's
their conclusion
the nation's laws social norms and
patterns of daily life
have all been revised in recent decades
to facilitate
the suppression of wage growth well
exactly but that's that's what we
populace have been telling you
for the last 10 years the question is
what to do about it
and the new york times only practical
suggestion is that
we begin by telling better stories
about the way the economy works thanks
new york times
i'm sure beleaguered workers everywhere
this time of year are going to run to
your website
and pour over every twisted tale you
tell
now what's remarkable about this
editorial is that the words president
trump
appeared nowhere in it and of course one
of the main reasons president trump was
elected
is that working class americans trusted
him
to strengthen the economy and improve
conditions for them
furthermore in this first term he
succeeded
this blows away expectations this is the
best number i've ever seen in my life
you can't contradict that these are the
best numbers of our lives
usmca historic trade agreement getting
support from both democrats
and republicans how significant minister
is this deal not just for the united
arab emirates and bahrain
uh and israel for that matter but for
the region it's pretty significant in
fact it's historic
a new narrative a narrative of hope and
a narrative
of prosperity well the times complains
about wage stagnation well but those
complaints are out of date as
we've told you many times real median
household income in the united states
grew by six thousand dollars from 2016
to 2019.
now forgive me for actually dealing in
facts tonight in 2019
median weekly earnings of full-time
workers increased by four percent
so we don't need better stories about
wages we just need to study the policies
that we pursued under president trump
and understand why they worked
now lucky for us it only takes a basic
understanding of econ 101 to explain the
success
of america first policies now for
starters wages
are the price that businesses pay for
labor right well like any other price
wages are determined by the law of
supply and demand
so if you want wages to increase you
should start by encouraging demand
that means keeping taxes low and
eliminating unnecessary regulations
president trump and the republicans in
congress encourage american businesses
to hire more workers that's good but
that's not enough which is why president
trump
restricted the supply of labor
he used tariffs and trade policies that
were smart to make it harder for
companies
to shift jobs offshore and by enforcing
immigration laws putting tighter
controls on work visas
president trump made it harder for
businesses to drive down wages for
american workers
by just flooding the market with
immigrants
these policies were extremely successful
that wasn't in the new york times
editorial
now by february 2020 the last month
before the pandemic
hit the u.s unemployment rate was only
3.5
now unfortunately biden and his
globalists will take us in the opposite
direction
now janet yellen biden's choice's
treasury secretary was ahead of the
federal reserve
for four years under obama and there's
no reason to believe that she's not
going to follow the same game plan that
biden advocated during the campaign
which is higher taxes more regulation
and a greater hostility toward business
certainly that we've seen in the push
for lockdowns etc
now on the other hand there's going to
be huge giveaways to unscrupulous
companies
that prefer not to pay a decent wage to
americans
because under biden it's going to be
easier to offshore jobs and then use
illegal labor to fill the holes
thus they will kill the demand
for american labor so the average
american worker
ends up getting shafted again under
biden's rules
now biden's pick to head omb you've
heard a lot about her tonight nira
tandon
she claimed that rising income
inequality was the consequence of
decades of conservative attacks on
workers rights to organize
and that labor unions are a powerful
vehicle to move workers into the middle
class and keep them here
okay i have a question from ms tandon
what happens when a union goes to
management
and demands a pay raise well what
happens then when management says
okay we're going to move our company to
india then
bye of course the focus on income
inequality is foolish
building up the middle class as trump
did is the way to go
and by the way even if you believe in
their stated goal income inequality
you don't help bridge the income
inequality by hammering the middle class
which exactly is what's happening in
places like california
and new york people say i don't like the
restrictions i have covert fatigue
how can you say i shouldn't have more
than 10 people in your house this is
where the spread is coming from
more restrictions placed on you more
businesses now
vulnerable to being out of business
permanently
well given their liberal leadership and
super democrat majorities
these states forget covet push covet
aside for a moment
these should be workers paradises right
but even before the pandemic before all
those talks of lockdowns and
restrictions
people were fleeing new york and
california
the middle class is virtually
non-existent in the big cities in both
states
there's the rich and then there's
everyone else
now check out the exit polls among those
who said the economy was the most
important issue to them
82 percent of those voters went for
trump
well these voters were just fed up with
the old trade deals the old policies
that gave away the store to places like
europe and china
of course biden is going to push the
trans-pacific partnership
and that's just designed to make it
easier for multinational companies
to lay off workers here and then shift
their production to places like vietnam
malaysia
and of course china the 74 million
americans who voted for president trump
already know this
now we have to take that message to the
working class people
all across the country oh and all of you
voters in georgia
i hope you understand what's at stake
here by sending kelly luffler and david
perdue back to washington
you will send a powerful message to dc
return to the failed policies of the
past and we will block you
in the senate and fight you every step
of the way
under biden's team of false prophets
which is really just the old obama team
the rich will get richer as the working
people
get stiffed once again with stagnating
wages
and i think more and more americans and
all 50 states
will be interested in learning about why
incomes soared under president trump
republicans running in 2022 and 2024
they have an easy answer we know what
works
elect us and we'll do it all over again
and that's the angle